Did I tell you the story when a one of my friends was offered to buy from me.
So I was in Upper Egypt and,
uh,
I was traveling with a young lady and,
a third woman,
a little bit older,
sort of was traveling alone.
It's not terribly comfortable.
She asked to join us and said,
that's fine.
So the three of us were sitting there,
uh,
in near [inaudible] and um,
there was,
uh,
two men sitting sort of across the room.
One of them dressed in clearly Arab garb and one restroom rather modern,
you know,
suit.
And at some point,
uh,
the,
the guy in the suit came over,
introduced himself very politely,
and he was a Palestinian and the other man was a Saudi Arabian shake.
And they had noticed that I had two wives.
And uh,
so the shake had,
uh,
wanted to know,
would like to purchase the second one,
the older one,
the second wife for me.
And since it was the somewhat older one,
he thought I wouldn't mind.
It was very much,
it was,
it was a wonderful scene because as you know,
Palestinians very sophisticated,
they've been living with Jews,
you know,
we're basically Europeans for a very long time,
so they're just like anybody else.
Uh,
but the,
the Saudi Arabian shake was obviously living not in the modern world.
And this port Palestinian had an intermediate so he was very scared.
And you know how I would respond to what I make a scene with.
I slugged him,
I tried to get him arrested or you know,
any of this sort of stuff.
But of course it was immediately obvious to me what was going on and to,
to,
to my two lady friends.
And so we played it.
Very cool.
And please sit down,
let's discuss this.
You know,
how old,
how old is their shake?
How many wives does he already have?
How many has he divorced?
Does he have any concubines in addition to his wives,
how much money he had,
et cetera.
Said we have very,
very nice,
polite thing.
And you could just see the intermediary,
you know,
his face.
Just relax.
You know,
cause he was,
he was expecting,
you know,
something terrible,
but everybody played along.
It went off very well.
And in the,
in the,
in the middle of this,
um,
the,
the shake calls the intermediary over back to him and they talk something and
outcomes a,
a velvet purse given to the Palestinian.
Then he gives me as a sign of good,
of good faith on the part of sorta hit.
And he wanted me to have this,
what is it,
a set of Muslim prayer beads,
beautiful cat size stones.
Many not just a champion,
beautiful,
uh,
handiwork and probably very valuable.
I was looking for to bring to yes,
actually last time and I can't find it right now.
Um,
but everything worked out.
The woman paid very great attention to what was going on and uh,
we said politely at the end that we would consider and give them an answer
tomorrow.
And uh,
in the end she didn't want to be bought even though she was obviously going to
have some good chunk of change out of it,
or at least I was.
Okay.
Uh,
the other two,
uh,
things will have to be delayed because Ellie is areas not here.
And we have to add something to know as presentation.
Okay,
let's get that.
So last time we were discussing Europe and uh,
we were coming into the,
we start discussed the middle ages and we start with Europe because we have the
best data.
We have very,
very good data about lots and lots of things from Europe.
It's not so good from the rest of the world.
And from about for about 500 years,
from 1200 to 1700,
the data poor is,
the data is a shows a population really didn't rise a terribly much.
They were in some sort of,
uh,
of,
of a Stacy bus.
And the reasons for this,
uh,
where we've discussed a little bit,
we talked about the plague and the plague lasted like 500 years.
Um,
since we're going to skip the to ash,
this is,
um,
oops.
Here we go.
So remember the plague hit Europe in 1347.
So this table where they have good data starts 200 years later.
The plague has been around for 200 years.
And still there's a number of cases that's not individual,
not individuals with different cities and places in which there was an outbreak.
And we just don't have good records of how many people died.
But 15,
50,
1600,
16,
50,
see,
the plague is dying out slowly.
And there's many,
many theories,
whether people got resistance to it or the rats that carried had died.
Uh,
we're outcome pay out,
competed by another species of rats,
not known,
but the plague did eventually die out.
But from 1347 to 1849 is 500 years where the plague keeps recurring.
So that was clearly one of the reasons why population couldn't grow.
Then there was violence.
It was constant small level violence.
And then when the Protestant reformation happened to religious wars broke out.
And uh,
according to,
uh,
one of the standard textbooks of European history,
they ran from 1531 up to 1657.
So another hundred and 30 years of slaughter.
And they rolled around different places in Europe.
And by the time they were done,
the most contested southern Europe,
uh,
stayed Catholic in the very northern became Protestant,
but the middle of Europe was strongly contested.
And so something like a third to a half of everybody got killed,
uh,
in this time because of the religious wars.
This is the period that mall office is describing and we'll come back to office
that Martha's knew about.
This is the history that he understood and we'll come back to what his theories
were.
But historians now agree pretty much that productivity of the land,
especially agriculture because that was the,
the main occupation was rising very slowly during this period.
But populations also rising very slowly during this period.
So pretty much the gains in agricultural productivity were balanced by the Games
in population and the average standard of living,
uh,
did not improve.
And we'll talk a good bit more about that
now.
Why?
So the question,
uh,
I mean it's pretty obvious why they were not able to improve agricultural
productivity,
why they were not able to significantly improve any other kind of manufacturing
code activity,
why they're were not able to do anything to fight these diseases.
And it comes down to that not only was there no science,
scientific knowledge as we currently understand the word scientific,
there really wasn't any particular interest in intellectually in the real world.
Everything was focused on religion and the,
the,
the other world.
So there was not a lot of intellectual energy expended in trying to understand
what was going on around your feet,
so to speak.
And because that all kinds of problems that we take for granted,
all kinds of ways of dealing with the real world,
just we're not even,
we're not really thought about in any serious way.
So sanitation up until the 18th century,
up until the 18 hundreds,
actually,
uh,
the sanitation in Europe was just absolutely atrocious.
Uh,
there was no system for disposing of human waste.
Nobody bothered to pay attention to what to do with human ways and feces.
We're basically everywhere.
Wherever you went there,
there was someone else's,
uh,
feces
in the 18th century.
Uh,
the city streets everywhere had ditches down the middle of the street.
And that's where the feces got done.
There were buckets inside the house and some servant or the housewives would
take the bucket and dump it into these ditches.
Um,
and they're also used as latrines.
People would just go out there and they didn't have a bucket in the house.
They didn't have a house go in and do it in the latrine.
Again,
in each case,
I'm going to pick,
I was in Belize,
Belize City and in Latin America and Central America as you know,
not that many years ago in the middle of the street as one big latrine in the
stink was just incredible.
Um,
so,
uh,
now you didn't actually have to,
we're not required to actually take your bucket of feces and dumped them in the
street.
You could throw them out your window and,
but eventually people did start thinking about that and the issue was not a
dumping on someone's head.
And,
uh,
in Edinburgh,
Edinburgh in Scotland,
they rang bells at 10:00 PM at night when they figured people should be off the
street.
And that was the specified time for dumping excrement out your window.
Some of the older view that were properly brought up for young men who may be
told that you should walk on the street side when you're as escorting a young
lady.
Do you know what that's for?
When stuff gets dumped out the window,
it's not to prevent spat splash from cars.
It's,
it's way be way earlier than cars.
It was too,
so that when someone dumped stuff out the window,
it would,
uh,
the lady would be under some kind of earnings there.
Um,
and it wasn't only the common people,
the poor,
the uneducated,
uh,
that we're living in such fills,
it went right up to the royalty.
So,
and we have records of this in 1665,
there was a great plague in London,
one of those that I've showed you there.
And that's the one that written about by a Robinson Crusoe author,
Daniel Defoe.
And so king the King Charles the second,
uh,
in his court took his refuge in Oxford University.
Now,
Yay.
I was modeled after a lot of Yale's model after Oxford.
So you have a good image of what it looks like.
And the play goes over.
Took about a year that plays over there.
They went back to London and just left whatever they laughed in Oxford in the
cleaning people came in.
And what did they find?
Excrement everywhere.
They described the excrement in every corner in chimneys and studies in coal
houses,
in sellers,
uh,
just all over the place.
Now,
some of this information comes from the diary of Samuel Peppers.
How many of you are aware of this?
Some of you,
again,
if you've taken a history or literature,
he was a famous diarist.
Uh,
from that he was England's first secretary of the admiralty,
a member of parliament,
president of the Royal Scientific Society.
So he was not your ordinary average guy.
He was educated and money and the upper classes,
but he writes it,
he didn't,
when he had to dedicate and in the middle of the night,
he didn't bother to go to the privy.
Uh,
he just as positive his feces in the fireplace.
So,
uh,
you can see that it was a smelly place to live in.
Now along with that,
no concern or no thought about where your deposit,
your excrement,
uh,
the idea of keeping drinking water separate from this action,
it was not in anybody's mind that very often,
if they were public of holes of,
of someplace where the public could go to do their thing,
then maybe right next to it was a drinking fountain.
Uh,
and in terms of the waste in the streets,
um,
it wasn't just feces,
but everything else was just dumped into the streets.
So,
uh,
England,
especially lots of animals,
you are,
you're a Penn animals on,
on like China.
And,
um,
when animals died just left in the middle of the street to rot butchers that
pulled out the end trails,
the guts of the animals and edible parts dump it in the street.
Uh,
and so the streets were just full of not only human exome,
put the waste of,
of all the animals.
And of course the flies and insects lay their eggs in it and,
and,
and grow.
And it's very unsanitary.
A dead people were not handled any better than this.
As more people died,
the urban cemeteries got filled up.
It was not,
uh,
so much space.
And so they stopped burying the poor people in properly in cemeteries,
but just what they called poor holes,
just a large pits in which piles of bodies were just laid a outside by side
robot row,
by row and row on top of row.
And they were not closed until they were full.
So you had these pits of rotting bodies just festering there in the middle of
all the cities that have enough people to Barry.
And of course the stench was just overwhelming and the rich people were not
buried in these pits.
But if they were,
it could be buried in cemeteries.
But if they're really important,
they bought space in the church crypt or they contributed money and got space in
the church.
Crip,
you know,
many of you have undoubtedly going to churches and in the basement they've got
these crypts of dead people.
And,
uh,
again,
guess what they were rotting and,
and strengths.
So the churches,
uh,
stank and a one code is that they stank out Parson and congregation that people
just couldn't stand to be there
in 1742,
Dr. Johnson,
who you know,
wrote the life of Boswell,
uh,
I'm,
I'm sorry,
by his Boswell's life of Johnson.
So He's quoting Johnson,
uh,
describe London as a city quote,
which abounds which such heaps of filth as a savage would look on with
amazement.
So,
uh,
the death rates cities were so unhealthy from all this fills that the death
rates were enormously high and cities did not keep themselves going.
It left to itself a city's population would just disappear.
And some estimates are about every generation,
about a third of the inhabitants of a city,
wood,
wood.
I mean,
everybody died.
But the population left of the city just left to itself,
would go down by a third in every generation.
And the only reason that cities were able to prosper is that in the countryside
where things were healthier,
just because of space,
there wasn't the demography,
there wasn't the,
the crowding,
uh,
of people that constantly the excess births,
the excess population from the countryside would keep migrating into the cities
because,
uh,
they had primogenitor and England for instance,
only the oldest son could inherit the land.
So younger sons had a migrate into the cities or into the army.
And,
uh,
that's what kept the city's going as a constant stream of people coming in from
the countryside.
Now it's not a London in the great cities and it's not only that part of Europe,
but we have descriptions of some of the other cities.
And one of them is currently politically a very relevant,
uh,
Jerusalem.
And,
uh,
now all the great western religions claim that Jerusalem is central to their
religion and they've,
they compete viciously.
They fight viciously over Jerusalem,
and they all claim that they've been interested forever,
you know,
in this.
But in fact,
it was until,
until Napoleon,
uh,
expedition to Egypt in the Middle East,
it was totally ignored as a physical thing from the crusades to Napoleon.
It was,
it was totally ignored in 1840.
It was a tiny town of 15,000 people,
uh,
7,000 Jews,
5,000 Muslims,
3000 Christians from the records that we have in a place like that,
presumably the,
the seat of,
of the Western religions,
the feces,
we're 50 feet deep and had been collecting since the destruction of the second
temple by the Romans.
Before the Romans destroyed Jerusalem.
There was some sort of sanitation going on.
Uh,
but uh,
between them and 1840,
the feces just kept,
kept going up.
Of course,
by the,
in this filth,
everybody was sick.
Basically everyone had malaria.
Malaria was endemic there.
When cholera came through,
which you came periodic is 75% of the people would die of it.
And one quote describing this,
the sanitary condition of the city of God ensured that any pilgrim who sought
to,
who sought to spend his last days on earth there could look forward to
fulfilling that ideal with great dispatch.
So personal cleanliness,
this was also unknown.
Uh,
we have one professor of medieval history who gives a great lecture and few she
ever gives it as a public lecture that I've seen him give if he ever gives it
again,
absolutely go.
It's called a thousand years without a bath.
So this is in Europe.
Uh,
the Romans,
uh,
we're very careful about personal cleanliness and they built these great big
baths and we visited like the baths of Caracalla in,
in Rome.
A couple of you have,
how about the bath bath?
The city in England named after its baths and so forth?
Well,
these are Roman a crane.
So the Romans,
uh,
very careful as much as they could in a place like that with personal hygiene.
But after the fall of Rome,
the morality changes,
the church takes over and the church wants people to concentrate on their souls,
not on their bodies.
And washing was considered too much a sign of preoccupation with the body.
And especially for women,
it's not good for women to pay too much attention to their bodies.
Um,
so
uh,
Europeans at that time boasted,
and you've probably heard this,
that they only washed three times in their lives.
How many of you have heard that once when they're born,
once they get married and once when they die they get washed through and the
rest of that,
not only didn't they wash,
they thought that water that you wash with carry disease contagion,
you know,
various theories and that if you watched,
you would probably get sick from the washing.
So the solution was not cleanliness,
the solution to the bad conditions,
but perfume and perfume comes up in this era because people stank so much that
if they had the money,
they would buy a perfume.
Anybody know why?
Yeah,
louder.
Louder.
Some water.
Was it?
Good question.
Was the water likely to make them sick if they drank the water?
Yes.
If they washed in the water,
no.
There's very little in temperate zone waters that are going to get through your
skin in a tropical zones that can be parasites in there and they can be
dangerous.
But in in Europe,
I'm not sort of aware of anything that washing in the water.
We'll,
we'll,
we'll get you,
get you sick.
So watch yourself stays on your skin and then leave or something.
Yes.
Again,
if you wash yourself,
it stays on your,
your skin and then you eat with your unwashed hands.
Well,
probably what was on there before he washed.
It's going to be worse in general.
I think nobody washed unless something comes off that,
that the burden of whatever's on there,
it gets less.
So all of these things are what we modern people think about.
And obviously back then,
just these kind of very simple,
straightforward questions.
We're not really,
uh,
considered people back then,
George Washington,
King George wore wigs.
Anybody know?
Some of you probably know why,
why they wear wigs.
Underneath the wig was
good luck.
Slice
lots of lice.
Shaved heads.
They had lice.
Lice was endemic.
They couldn't get rid of it.
So they shaved their heads.
I think we just saw that on television with the John Adams Story.
K every cell from Denny,
if you see that TV show Hbo.
Anyway,
he takes off his,
his,
his wig and there he is bald.
Uh,
that was to prevent a lice.
Okay.
So one of the reasons,
uh,
one of the major reasons for this lack of population growth for hundreds of
years in Europe,
just no idea about sanitation,
hygiene,
any of this kind of stuff.
Another aspect which you'll be reading about,
uh,
is infanticide.
Infanticide was a very large factor in European demography and the rest of the
world is,
it will read about.
But,
uh,
in Europe it was very important.
In the,
uh,
there was always a,
a level of infanticide and,
uh,
various sorts.
But in the 18th and 19th centuries,
that apparently exploded the number of kids that were done away with in Milan.
Uh,
from 1840 to 1860s,
one third of all children born to married parents.
We're not talking about unmarried situations.
We're left at foundling homes.
And,
uh,
in founding homes,
the death rate was near 100%.
Uh,
more than half of all the children born to working class parents were left and
founding homes and almost all the illegitimate children were abandoned.
And the death rates,
it was a form of infanticide.
You just gave it into a foundling home.
They were taken basically no care of.
They died.
It was out of sight.
And again,
not just the ordinary ignorant person,
but you all know Sean Shock Russo,
the famous French philosophic and wrote a lot that encouraged the American
revolution.
Uh,
this is a quote from him.
My third child was,
does deposited in a foundling home just like the first two.
And I did the same with the two following.
I had five.
And all the arrangements seemed to me so good,
so sensible,
so appropriate that if I did not boast of it publicly,
it was solely out of regard for their mother,
that there was no here,
they're,
they're abandoning these children,
uh,
to almost certain death and it not,
there was just no moral compunction about it whatsoever,
aside from absolute abandonment to founding homes or other just leaving them in
the streets.
You'll read about American in England where the kids were just often left in the
streets.
Um,
another mechanism was sending our children to nurse with wet nurses.
And,
uh,
the death rate of wet nurse children was enormously high.
So if parents tried to rear their children,
the death rate was about one in six at,
at this,
at this time,
uh,
but in 18th century,
France,
between a half and two thirds of infants that were set out to nurse died,
uh,
and,
and even in a higher death rate where the so called baby farms in,
in the 19th century Europe,
there were,
there's like,
we call him puppy mills now.
There were baby farms and they took in vast numbers of children to presumably
wet wet nurse,
but almost none of them survived.
And as I showed you from these and all kinds of reasons,
about a third of children died in infancy.
The idea of being a parent and the family idea of child rearing was completely
different.
Uh,
then we now understand.
So the standard thing was a child is born,
it's almost immediately sent out to wet nurse,
someone that doesn't care about them.
A lot was written about wet nurses getting drunk row,
having the baby in bed,
getting drunk,
rolling over on the baby and squashing the baby.
Whether that was an excuse or,
or the real reason for the child's death is,
is unknown.
But they would wet nurse for,
uh,
for a couple of years.
And then those that were still alive would come back home,
uh,
maybe,
age two or three or something.
And then by age seven,
they would be sent back out to work again as an apprentice somewhere.
And how many of you read Charles Dickens and David Copperfield and Oliver twist
or what age would they sent out to work?
Seven.
Seven is the standard age.
This is scenes of one of the Dickens' characters going to work in a dye factory
dying cloth and comes out black everyday covered,
uh,
with the dye.
And so that was,
that was quite a standard thing in 1646.
Uh,
they're very rich and very progressive town of Leiden in the Netherlands.
Leiden was one of the most advanced places in Europe.
Limited the working day to children to 14 hours.
Whether the law was obeyed or not,
we don't know.
But children could not do that.
And of course,
Charles Dickens is a couple of hundred years later in the 19th century.
And apparently in every one of his novels there's some scene of child labor
going on.
Now I'm talking about up to the 18 hundreds,
but this does not disappear.
Now you look what Europe,
the situation Europe was in an 1800.
Some of the developing countries are currently in so official figures from
India.
The government figures say there are 12 million child workers in India,
opponents activists on,
on the labor issue estimate that it's closer to 60 million children in India are
working.
Uh,
the Cha,
they do have child labor laws now in India and they prohibit children under age
14 from working in hazardous jobs.
Uh,
when the scandal about gap,
our clothing manufacture gap came out.
Uh,
the factories that were investigated had children as young as 10 years old
working up to 16 hours a day and making the dungarees and a lot that,
that we were.
Yeah.
So all of this sort of misery,
uh,
leads not only physical,
misery,
but a change in attitude toward,
toward life and death came very easily.
It was very common.
And so life was,
was cheaper and there's no question about it from the,
from the literature.
The life was cheaper than we,
we consider now.
And because children's specialty,
we're so likely to die as well as anyone else.
It was considered an imprudent,
not,
not wise to be particularly affectionate with or emotionally entwined with any
other human being.
Your husband might die immediately or kids might die,
your wife might,
might die.
And so as far as we can tell from the writings of the period,
what we call an effective relationships with emotional relationships,
rather cool in this period,
except of course violent anger,
which always pops out.
So
going back
to this,
so here's all these problems and what did people do about some of these things?
And so,
um,
in
the idea of disease comes from the Greeks and probably farther back than the
Greeks that the body is controlled by four humors,
fluids that run around the body.
Something like the chief of,
of,
of Oriental
thought,
uh,
and these four humans must be in balance.
And when you got sick,
the problem was that the humors got out of balance.
So one of the things you did was get bled.
That was a standard procedure.
Let the blood flow because of that gets rid of the evil humors.
And George Washington was apparently killed by an excess of bloodletting.
So when he was older,
he got quite sick and the doctors as well while he was sick,
blood five pints of blood out of him and then he died.
So we take,
when we go to take blood,
they take one pint and they consider that sort of the maximum safe mount for
young,
healthy people.
Here he was old and sick,
five pints.
He dies
his nemesis or nemesis or the George Washington in America and King George the
third in England,
you know the saying mad king George,
you know,
he was mad and he was mad with a genetic disease called Porphyria,
which affects the,
the hemoglobin in the blood and uh,
it caused episodic madness.
So he would be saying then he'd be mad.
He'd be saying that he'd be mad and when he was mad,
what did they do?
They bled him.
They bled him enormously.
They tied him to a chair that had all kinds of things to him.
They had no clue either a,
how to handle any of these,
these nor of a humane way.
No idea of a humane way to treat someone who has something wrong with them that
you have no clue what it is or,
or what to do about this.
And if you ever want to see that there's a great movie,
the madness of King George about 1995 [inaudible].
They,
it,
it described this,
this aspect of his life life.
Uh,
so leeches,
another form of this bloodletting was instead of taking a razor blade or blade
and cutting a vein,
which is hard to sew up,
leeches are wonderful.
So you,
you stick leaches on you and the blood,
uh,
leeches,
suck out the blood.
And we know this goes back,
at least to the ancient Romans,
and it was practice for 2000 years.
This bloodletting on this ancient theory of the humors,
1860,
we have data in the hospitals just in London.
So in 1860,
that was rule Britannia England was the richest,
most educated ruler of the whole world,
right?
1860.
And the hospitals in one city in London,
7 million leaches were used.
The idea again being that until
you know what you're doing,
you don't know what you're doing and just use anything and it's all no evidence
whatsoever that any of this ever helped anybody.
And of course we now know it was in fact not only didn't help them,
it made them sicker.
So,
uh,
we now have a sort of a rage in America and Europe
for natural medicine,
medicine and,
and,
and its various versions.
Well this is has very old history.
And so how many know the author Wilkie Collins,
moonstone,
woman and white there?
One of the,
they're on PBS television all the time.
You,
you've seen them.
Uh,
so he had gout,
which was,
uh,
what happens is,
back then they had a lot of meat.
I had a lot of protein in the blood.
The breakdown product protein is urea.
If you can't,
don't excrete it fast enough,
it's not very soluble.
It crystallizes in your joints.
And then every time you move a joint,
the little sharp crystals grind in there and it makes it very hard to move.
And your joints get swollen.
Very,
very unpleasant disease.
So what did they do for gout in the Ed?
Later the 1880s,
they treated gout with a poultice of cabbage leaves covered with Silk,
with oiled silk.
And uh,
this particular author Wilkie Collins wrote about it.
That's how we,
we know some of the details and it didn't give him any relief whatsoever.
Surprise,
surprise.
So what he did,
he turned to opium to dull the pain cause opium really does work.
It's the basis of morphine and he probably died partly of opium poisoning
because it does other bad things to your system.
Now,
continuing this,
this story of what happened,
you know,
this all relates to death rates in,
in pre scientific,
uh,
times.
So,
uh,
your American history buffs,
what happened to President James Garfield?
He was assassinated.
He was shot,
but he wasn't really,
he was shot,
but he wasn't really assassinated because he lived like for a year after he was
shot.
So whether you call it an assassination on,
I don't know,
but the,
the,
the bullet went in apparently into his back and lodged and some fat.
Now fat is not very permeable to anything.
You're just like the bullet largest lump of fat.
The lead doesn't,
the lead poisoning from the bullet doesn't get out.
Nothing much gets out.
So it's not a really dangerous thing to have a,
a bullet,
uh,
in,
in a lump of fat.
But his doctors and some of them were homing at paths,
which was the big thing back then,
and some newer aloe paths.
And what those words mean,
you can ask me after after class,
and they had opposing theories.
So many paths thought that whatever was wrong with you.
And so I am telling you the theories,
but everyone was wrong with you.
You should give a little bit of the same thing and that would cure you.
And little bit meant you could dilute it infinitely so that there's actually
nothing in what they were giving you.
Maybe pure water,
but that was supposed to cure you.
Allopath was supposed to give them something of the opposite.
And there's been homes.
You can see every drugstore nowadays,
homeopathic remedy and what that legally means has nothing in it,
you know,
uh,
if that's okay.
And so,
but they had these opposite theories.
And they kept fighting about what to do,
uh,
with,
this president who was,
was sick.
So what they did is they stuck a metal rods into his wound to try to,
you know,
pull the bullet out,
even though the bullet was new,
doing no danger,
although sterilization,
uh,
had a list or had done his work,
it was known already.
These doctors didn't believe in that.
So they stuck in these metal rods,
uh,
with no sterilization and,
it was not,
he of course,
got infected apparently not from the bullet because he lived a year,
but from the metal rods that they kept poking end with him.
Their understanding or their interest in,
uh,
in physiology was so nil that they insisted for reasons that I have not found
that he'd be fed rectally.
So they fed him beef Pujan,
egg yolks,
milk whiskey and drops of opium,
opium recto.
And the problem is the rectum does not absorb food.
The purpose of the recommendation is to take water out and conserve,
conserve water.
So they're feeding in this way.
This is the only way he's allowed to be feed.
It's not healthy to put food in this way.
And so what happens,
what do you think happens?
He loses weight.
How much weight?
You lose a hundred pounds from July to September.
In three months this guy loses a hundred pounds.
Does anybody notice this?
Does anybody pay attention to this?
Does anybody have the scientific clue of mine that well I have a theory and I'm
applying that theory and oh my,
it's not working.
So maybe my theory is wrong.
No,
that's just not the,
the critical scientific mindset.
They knew that that was the right thing to do and so they would not give up
their theories and basically it seems he starved to death.
You know,
they infected him and starved him to death.
So what happens when new ideas do come out in a,
in a,
in a pre a
pre scientific ear.
So one of the current public health measures is you don't eat food with your
hands,
right?
Your mother tells you that all the time,
cause you wash your hands first,
which they didn't do.
But even then you eat with a knife and fork.
What your mother has or,
or of your dishwasher has,
has,
uh,
cleaned very nicely.
So Europeans,
of course,
as you've seen from any movie,
uh,
eight with their hands for many hundreds of years.
But at that time the Arabs were much more civilized than we were.
We either Europeans,
uh,
and so,
and the Lavant,
uh,
the,
the Middle Eastern coast,
there were,
Venice had lots of commerce.
They were already eating with knives and forks.
And you know,
you use the fork.
Well,
this was first introduced into the Europe by the Duke of Venice,
the Doge of Venice.
And his wife became aware that the,
the Arab civilization was,
was doing this,
this thing of eating with forks and she thought she would introduce it into her
dinner parties.
So she started having forks at,
at her dinner party.
And,
uh,
the,
there was a,
the cardinals,
uh,
one of the cardinals at that time was Saint Peter Damien.
And he says that he was just totally opposed to this.
And the idea was that the stuff that you eat are animals.
And plants,
they're God's creations.
And that by using a fork,
she had set herself up above God's creation.
And the quote is,
um,
uh,
to touch me with a fork was impious Lee to declare that God's creatures,
we're not worthy of being touched by human hands.
And that kind of phrase was repeated,
uh,
all the way into the 17th century.
And forks came very slowly into Europe,
a lightening rods.
When Benjamin Franklin invented lightning rods,
what was most likely to get struck by lightning?
It was the church steeple,
right?
Cause they stuck up into the sky and had points.
And as you may know,
if you take physics points,
attract lightning pointy things.
So churches are always getting lightning and burned out.
So he,
uh,
Benjamin Franklin invents the lightening Rod and Oh my God,
the,
the opprobrium that,
that he came under because lightening was obviously a one of God's creations
that he was punishing people with it.
Now Benjamin Franklin was interfering with God's punishment.
So going back to the family,
which are relevant to this population,
more than lightning.
Um,
so one of the,
of this whole,
this whole brutal society in which life is very insecure,
people are very violent to each other.
They're not careful with their persons or anything like that.
Child rearing practices don't,
don't escape.
Uh,
this whole context in which people lived and the traditional Christian view in,
in the West,
uh,
and this is strongly reinforced by Calvinist theology after,
after the reformation,
was that children are born with original sin.
Original sin is the view of human nature.
What is human nature considered being these times now we think of human nature
is genes versus environment.
But back then it was original sin and children were born into sin and the only
hope of holding the sin and check was thought to be the most ruthless repression
of child's will and his total subordination to the will of the parents.
He was married to him,
to his parents,
to school masters,
and to anyone with authority over him.
Theologians and moralists insisted that parents ruthlessly crushed the wills of
young children by physical force if necessary.
So,
and that has political ramifications if you're taught when you're young and your
parents believe that the most moral thing is that you must be obedient.
You must not have a will of your own.
This leads you to believe that authoritarian,
uh,
political structures are the normal and right way that humans should be
governed.
The American puritans are,
we're very much a part of this.
And the primary concern with respect your childbearing of American puritans was
in making children's sin free enough to merit an afterlife.
So they threatened totally healthy children by telling them that they would soon
die.
So Jonathan Edwards,
for whom one of the Yale colleges is named,
and he was president of Princeton,
he was not president of Yale once I said he was,
I was wrong.
Uh,
he lectured a group of children.
I know you will die and little time,
some sooner than others.
Tis Not likely,
you will all live to grow up.
Now,
you know,
children's storybooks,
one of the popular children's books was a token for children.
Quote,
if other children die,
why,
why may not you sicken and die?
So again,
we try to protect our children nowadays.
You know,
nurture,
loving,
tried to protect our children from these uh,
worries.
But back then,
one,
it was a reality and to that reality was used to suppress.
There was called then there their will and subject them to enforcement by the
parents.
And of course this in the literature,
there's a,
this sort of reading of history came about 50 years ago when this was sort of
noticed and there's been a large reaction to it that know some parents at least
were loving during this long stretch of European history.
And of course not,
none of all parents were sort of so brutal to their children.
Um,
but somewhere the,
uh,
the,
they,
they were,
uh,
one of the things was to force a child into the mold,
the behavioral mold that you liked him grow soon to the physical mold.
So girls weren't supposed to have narrow,
narrow bought us is now our ways.
And so there's a,
there's at least one case on record where a girl was put into an iron cage to
squeeze her.
And as she grew older,
uh,
the cage squeeze more and more and she couldn't breathe.
She died of suffocation from being put in this iron cage to mold her physical
body to the shape that was wanted by the parents.
And so the conclusion is that life in this,
um,
pre modern pre-scientific times was not only sort of miserable in the physical
sense,
but probably also quite miserable in an emotional,
in inward kind of sense that people were not warm and loving to each other very
much,
but,
uh,
very frequently cold and disciplining and,
and,
and controlling kind of people.
So,
uh,
so we have some centuries of this period and you can go back to maybe the fall
of the Roman empire when really learning,
really learning about reality in the west kind of stopped with the fall of Rome.
So you have more than a thousand years.
We're sort of no intellectual progress with the Spectra.
Reality is made and then things all of a sudden start to change.
And we're going to talk about that now.
Within 200 years,
uh,
the death rate falls dramatically.
And so has the birth rate falls dramatically.
And these changes are sort of the centerpiece of,
of water,
of course,
and demography,
historical demography.
Anyway,
usually studies called the demographic transition,
the form,
the death rate in the fall,
in the birth rate.
So the,
you'll,
you'll hear this many times because it's so basic that in these periods and old
periods,
the birth rate is very high.
The death rate is very high,
they're about equal.
So population basically grows not at all or very,
very slowly.
So what we're going to talk about now in turn is first the fall,
the death rate,
and the second,
then the fall in the birth rate.
And then the theories that we have to explain,
uh,
these enormous changes in the way of what it means to be a human being.
So,
Ooh,
what happened?
Uh,
we didn't,
we don't know the causes.
The or we have many,
many third,
maybe we many,
many times know what the causes are.
Uh,
one of those standards,
Standard Textbook of European history says coat one.
This is going back to the wars of religion,
which are just before all these changes started happening before Galileo,
for instance,
one thing was clear,
130 years of senseless bloodletting in the name of religion inevitably sparked
off a reaction in the minds of intelligent people.
The wars of religion offered fertile soil for the fragile seeds of reason and
science.
People began to realize that religiosity was hostile.
The civilization European says,
because of this period of sort of utter irrationality that the,
the,
the bad results of it were so immediately obvious to everyone.
Everyone was skinning scared,
getting killed by the people in the neighboring town who are of the other
religion.
Uh,
they rejected all of that and we're ready for some sort of a rational attitude
toward things.
And the results of that we can see we're really quite dramatic.
So here is what we can reconstruct of life expectancy and going back 8,000 years
ago where the records are very poor,
but it certainly wasn't much better than this.
And there was wavering and probably some slow increase in life expectancy.
This just above 20 years of life expectancy is what I showed you in that graph
of CIS Alpine Golf from Roman Times.
And what I've told you is true of Europe during these,
these hundreds of years that I've been talking about,
and that stays more or less the same with the perhaps some improvement.
It doesn't matter whether you're looking at France,
the dotted line,
or you're looking at China.
The solid line,
as far as we can tell,
they're pretty much the same until around 1700.
All of a sudden something majorly changes and the the,
the life expectancy goes,
starts going sky high.
So we're talking about not just one of many,
many things that happened in history that you can take all kinds of history
courses about.
But in terms of what it means to be a human,
you finally can stay alive beyond the age of 20 or 25.
And that is such a tremendous change in,
in,
in life that that there's nothing else,
uh,
as important.
And of course a large part of this or reinforced this was child infant
mortality.
And look what happens
back here.
It's going up and down like crazy that it's very high.
There's a quarter of children and this is,
uh,
a European data.
So this is about a fifth to a quarter of children die,
uh,
as,
as children.
And it's out of control.
You can see that they epidemics come through and then times get good and then
something else comes through.
And so it was very variable and very high.
And then it starts souping downward.
And not only does it come down,
but it evens out that the,
that we start getting control not only over the overall level,
but all the things which cause these wild swings in it.
So again,
uh,
an amazing,
change in,
in what it means to be humans.
Well,
what does this date where things start happening?
1770s.
We're into the enlightenment and you all have probably,
at least in your high school history,
I have heard of the enlightenment and that is the big opening out in Europe of
rational discourse on almost everything.
And everything from,
from science to politics and disease,
for instance,
uh,
was,
considered divine punishment upon mankind for their sins.
That's a quote somewhere.
Medical research was considered sack religious.
A dissection of cadavers was objected to because coat,
if you cut the bodies into pieces,
what's going to happen to them at the time of the resurrection.
So there all kinds of reasons that you shouldn't do anything to get even the
most basic knowledge of what's inside a human body.
And without that you can't make any progress.
The major,
major event in,
in the enlightenment is Newton's Principia newtons discussion of something that
sounds rather abstract.
You know what he was worried about was how the bodies go round in heaven.
That's what everyone was trying to figure out.
That you may remember,
Copernicus had already said that things didn't go around the earth,
but they went around the sun and that was older.
Kepler had gotten the mathematics rights,
so they went around,
not in circles but in ellipses,
but nobody had any explanation for this.
It was a simple theory was great regularity,
but no one had any idea why.
Newton's gravitation was what made it rational in the sense of understanding
that it was just as simple force of gravity and people don't always understand
the,
you know,
the story of the apple dropping on his head.
Right.
So that the stories that gave him the idea of gravitation,
no,
apparently one,
the story is probably apocryphal totally.
But the import is what everyone was trying to figure out was the heavenly
motions,
the moon around the earth,
the earth around the sun,
the planets around,
all of these sorts of things.
And so he goes to sleep under the tree and the apple falls on his head and he
wakes up and he realizes,
oh my God,
the apple fell on my head for the same reason that the moon is held in orbit
around the earth.
As you know,
if there was no gravity,
the moon would just,
here's the earth.
The moon goes around,
you shut off gravity,
the moon goes off in a straight line forever.
And that was kind of understood already by Galileo that that thing's in motion.
We'll go in a straight line unless you pull them in somehow.
So they knew that the earth,
the moon was constantly falling toward the earth.
The earth was constantly falling toward the sun.
All the planets were constantly flowing for the side that was understood.
And they knew that Apple's fell to the earth,
but they didn't put the two of them together.
The great insight of Newton apparently was realizing that this thing on earth
that we could observe and measure on earth with the same reason that the heavens
worked.
And this,
this was sort of a,
a bombshell that led to the whole theory of,
uh,
of,
of celestial mechanics and,
and gravitation and,
and all of western science really starts from this.
We did 25 years and people were Newton.
Newton was lying eyes during his lifetime.
It was realized what a tremendous achievement.
Uh,
this was,
uh,
and uh,
the,
the relationship that this is not only the scientific achievement that the,
that the,
the planets orbited by the same forces drops an apple,
but it was previously believed that yes,
well,
events on earth might work by some sort of physical laws.
You had Galileo on that,
but heaven was ruled by supernatural laws and now Newton's great insight was no,
they're the same laws that there's nothing special or different about the
heavens that they work by exactly the same laws as stones and Apple's flowing,
uh,
on earth.
This was really a tremendous impetus to,
to realize the power of rationality.
And so within 25 years,
the whole attitude,
everything changes tremendously.
Uh,
as the bubonic plague receded for reasons we don't know that I showed you that
data,
then smallpox starts becoming the leading cause of death,
one replacing the other.
So as,
uh,
as opposed to what had gone on before,
which was supernatural ideas about it.
And the 1710s or very shortly after Newton,
the royal scientific society again started at the same time,
began a search program,
research program to gather information from any place in the world on how
smallpox could be controlled or cured.
Just a new kind of way of dealing with disease that just hadn't been seen
before.
And so what did they find?
They found that in Turkey that they were inoculating,
uh,
people.
And what,
what inoculation is the early form is they take someone who has the disease,
they take pus from the disease and what is pus?
It's white blood cells that have eaten the virus and bacteria and depending
where the plague or smallpox and have engulfed it and they kill the bacteria,
virus,
the pathogen.
So we have a dead pathogen,
but it's molecules are still there.
And so you can take the pus injected cut,
just cut the skin and put it on a person and hopefully they're not exposed to
any more of the live virus,
but the dead,
presuming the white blood cells have killed the virus and you just get their
molecules and that induces an immune reaction and you become immune to this
disease.
Uh,
local governments,
uh,
started,
I'll tell you more about those smallpox in a couple of minutes.
Uh,
in 1750s,
again,
this very early time,
local regulations for storage dispose of sewage disposal are,
are getting started.
Uh,
in the 17,
nine days,
the rich start using water closets,
which are toilets a of some sort.
Now only doing introduce vaccination,
but 1796,
they try to make it better.
They don't just say,
oh,
this works by some magic.
They try to figure out what makes it better.
And Jenner discovers vaccination,
which is instead of using pass from a person who had smallpox,
there's a very closely related disease called cow pox,
which a cow maids the milkmaids get very frequently.
And it was notice,
cause they're now observing all these things that these women would get sick,
but most of them would recover.
This was not a lethal disease.
So instead of taking the actual smallpox virus,
which vaccination,
the early inoculation did not always work in you sometime did catch the disease
and died.
Taking it from cow pox rather than smallpox was less dangerous.
But since the,
the viruses are closely related to each other,
um,
there are a lot of,
the molecules are the same and you get it from cow pox,
you get immunity to small parks.
And so these diseases start going down.
And
so,
not only in health,
but it starts the industrial revolution.
Uh,
in 1711,
uh,
James Newcomen,
events,
uh,
the steam engine.
It's a very,
very inefficient steam engine and it's used only where you have,
can have a very big,
uh,
in placement.
And it's used to pump water out of mines.
Coal is becoming important,
uh,
for England to fuel the industrial revolution.
And we have,
mines are underground and water seeps into them.
You've got to suck out the water.
So how do you pump it out?
Well,
he invents the steam engine and then James Watt,
uh,
figures out,
looks at it more scientifically,
more rationally.
And again,
just like inoculation being supplanted with vaccination,
they start improving.
It's not just that something works in our ancestors did it this way and we don't
know why it works.
We don't care.
It works.
We do at the same way our ancestors did.
No,
they keep thinking about what they're looking at,
what they're working on,
any improves it.
And in this case,
what James Watt did is after the steam comes out,
he had a condenser to condense the steam.
So drop the pressure on one side of the piston going out.
So just by taking the condense that,
of letting,
having a way of cooling the steam,
uh,
really improves the efficiency of a steam engine.
And now with a greater efficiency,
you can make a smaller steam engine that works just as well,
and you can put it on wheels and you can start getting the railroad and all
kinds of smaller factories can start using steam engines.
MMM.
In politics,
this idea is also terribly important.
The previous idea was that of a hierarchical system,
who's God appointing kings being ruling it over nobility and then everyone else
must obey up this chain.
What was Newton's idea that everything obeys the same law.
Gravity that the son attracts the earth.
The earth attracts the sun equal and opposite.
There's no difference.
The Sun does not rule the universe.
It's not better than you know,
it works by exactly the same rule as the sun and the,
the earth and the moon.
The everything acts by the same rules.
There is no need for some sort of central Centi and coordinator of all this.
But each individual planet,
each individual body,
all bodies,
apples,
uh,
working by their own laws,
by the same laws as everyone else,
the universe works beautifully.
In fact,
it works as,
as it does work.
This idea is very consciously taken over into politics and the idea of democracy
again,
change that each person acting under his own desires,
his own self interest,
uh,
his own morality can by interacting in the same way the clients too can come out
with a system that works and the original theorists of democracy,
we're very,
very conscious of this shift in the way they looked at the way the universe
works and very conscious of it's uh,
it's their debt to Newton on that in economics,
how many of your economics majors?
Oh,
of the blue.
The bus has really taken effect.
We used to have lots of economic majors.
So what ends Adam Smith's idea?
The,
the,
the basis of,
of modern economics is Adam Smith's.
That,
no,
you don't need a merch until this government to control everything.
That if each person acts in their own self interest by their own internal rules,
then the economy will work just wonderfully and be a more productive,
uh,
freedom of religion is again the same thing.
Freedom of conscience is a similar kind of idea that each person has its own,
has his own way of working things in that does not destroy the harmony of the
universe.
And so,
um,
we see that this rationality a changes everything about the way humans live.
And one of its most important effects is demography.
That the population,
uh,
stop styling and can start increasing.
And this exactly what happens as all this rational attitude toward death and
towards disease starts taking hold.
The death rate falls tremendously as I've shown you.
The life expectancy goes up,
infant mortality goes down in population,
starts increasing tremendously.
Most people at that time believed that big population was a wonderful thing and
they're very optimistic about it.
And one of the standard ways of judging a government when you saw a country that
had a lot of people in it,
well obviously the government was doing something right.
The king at that time was doing something right because people were able to stay
alive.
If you saw a country with a low population while something was wrong and that
was not necessarily a,
an improper attitude.
And so up until office,
uh,
with some exceptions,
it was generally the idea that there was no limit to population,
that the more the population the merrier.
Moses came along and said,
hmm,
there is problems with population.
And um,
he had been watching,
uh,
you know,
he,
he collected very good dead.
He read,
you read his stuff.
It's really wonderful to read because it's extremely modern and that he tells
you the data he's collecting.
He analyzed it,
tells you what's,
what he,
what's wrong with the data,
why,
why he believes it to a certain extent,
but not beyond that.
And,
and all things about the era of the day,
of the date of very,
he's writing is like 1798.
But it reads like a modern,
uh,
phd thesis just about,
and
his,
his knowledge was,
was the following and it's,
and it's very simple what he said.
He did not say many people bought that as previous people had often said like,
like Edmund Burke,
who's a father of conservatives,
that the economic pie is constant.
There's just so much stuff out there.
And the more people you just have to divide the pie smaller and smaller.
So that's one way of looking at it.
And then it's perfectly obvious that population is,
is a bad thing cause there's fixed production and you have more people to eat up
that production.
No,
Moses was much smarter
by the time he wrote in 1798,
the enlightenment had started to produce results.
He could see that agricultural production,
uh,
was in improving year by year.
Modern methods,
uh,
we're modern at that time were beginning to take over.
And he knew that production rose and what he assumed and what he,
what he saw from the data was that production rose linearly,
that every year there was sort of,
you could produce a little bit more out of the land.
Now he said,
but what about population?
He said,
in population,
if you have a hundred people,
and they increased by let's say 50%,
that's 150 people.
You've gained 50 people,
but now from the next generation,
you again grow by 50%.
You're starting with 150 people you have now you're adding 75 people.
So the graph,
uh,
oh,
I have,
there is blackboard here.
This is time.
This is agricultural product.
And Martha said,
this is growing like this,
which was quite reasonable for his time.
But population,
no matter where it starts,
grows,
he called it geometrically.
We call it exponentially.
So if it starts that there's just enough food for people to eat,
uh,
then it almost immediately goes above food production.
If it starts even below,
it doesn't matter.
It eventually rises,
catches up with food production and goes beyond it.
So he believed that there was no doubt that population increases geometrically
or exponentially as,
as we say,
that means a certain percent a year in increased 1% a year or 2% a year or 3% a
year.
But remember that's 1% of an increasing number.
So it's more and more,
whereas agriculture,
he thought increased linearly by the same fixed amount each year.
And if that's the case,
you're gonna run into starvation.
So he said,
since,
uh,
since population can always outrun productivity,
eventually you get into trouble that whenever you increase the number of people,
uh,
if you ever,
so you're at some sort of status status level where resources fit the
population,
but then as you get some increase in productivity,
it allows a rise in population only to match that.
But then the greater number of people eat up that increase in productivity is
right back down to where you started with.
So his idea was that increasing population was not a good thing.
It could not lead to any improvement.
Uh,
if it Outran your productivity gains.
And this led to all kinds of what we now consider very conservative and even
retrogressive political ideas.
So poor laws,
he was initially against poor laws.
There's no sense to keep the poor live because if you keep them alive,
they're going to reproduce and make even more children.
And you're right back to where you started from.
Uh,
so he was a strong conservative,
uh,
in,
in that sense.
He later changed his mind as he got smarter about things he was also aware of,
even though population could increase like this maybe.
And he was aware that people were smart enough to stop this in some way.
So he knew about various methods of contraception,
withdrawal and so forth and various perverse sexual practices.
Uh,
but he was so opposed to them.
Marley,
as was everyone else in his time that you should not control reproduction,
that that was immoral.
But he said,
no,
people are never going to do that.
That what happens to balance it is not people themselves controlling this in a
very rational way,
which he thought was not possible at that time.
Uh,
but,
uh,
family would come in,
disease would come in and whenever your population got too big,
people would get very poor.
They were open to some disease.
The disease would wipe you out.
So either starved directly,
immediately from,
uh,
too much the population getting ahead of agricultural productivity,
you gonna starved or you've got so weak that diseases come through and wipe you
out.
Okay.
We will,
uh,
time is up.
We will continue onward next time.